New York Times bestselling author
Gretchen Rubin has investigated the link
between happiness and human nature for
the past decade her books have sold more
than three and a half million copies
worldwide and her award-winning podcast
happier with Gretchen Rubin has more
than 66 million total downloads her new
book is Outer order intercom declutter
and organized to make more room for
happiness Rubin offers more than 120
tips for organizing our lives move in
good morning barri a note by the way
that Gail has left we haven't we haven't
decluttered the table she's off on
assignment
what is outer order you know outer order
is when we've just cleared away
everything that's clogging our space
we've gotten rid of things that we don't
use don't need don't love and some
people want to be left with more they
love abundance
some people want simplicity but it's
getting rid of everything that's just in
our way why does it make you happy you
know there's just this weird connection
for most people between outer order and
inner calm and inner focus on even a
sense of possibility not everybody feels
this way some people are truly clutter
blind and they don't see it they don't
care but for most people it gets rid of
bad feelings it makes you feel more
engaged with your things you can find
things more easily life is easier so for
many people it's daunting to take on the
clutter that they both recognize and
then all the stuff that they don't
recognize is cluttering up their life so
what's the first simple step that they
can take to climb this Everest well the
first thing is don't get organized
because a lot of people are like I need
to get organized so I'm gonna get a
filing cabinet and fancy hangers and a
cat you know since a set of containers
first you want to get rid of everything
you don't use Nate or love and then
maybe you don't need to organize
anything at all because you don't need a
filing cabinet because you only have
three documents left and then to add as
a question do I need a do I use to do I
love it because if you don't need it use
it or love it why do you have it
it's the cord to nowhere to nothing you
can get rid of that it's a great book
because the number one you say make
choices and you actually start with with
the closet which is really where most of
us keep most of the junk that we don't
need or love and you say through you
know does it fit is it interchangeable
is it uncomfortable all of these choices
that help but does it add Beauty all of
those sorts of things too
work through that only why after that
can you then create essentially order
why do you have to make the choice first
well the choice there is decision
fatigue it's hard it's emotionally
draining it's intellectually draining
but once all that stuff has been wiped
away you know given away recycle donated
that's when you can really see where do
I put things how do we organize things
so I can find them easily so they make
sense to me so they look appealing but
if you start by trying to organize
things then you're gonna organize things
that you don't need to keep it all and
that's just extra work and you don't
have the room for it on your show what
else you keep things because someday you
might love them okay this is somebody
someone is going to like this thing be
very honest with yourself you know
someday someone you know are they really
gonna want your 15 year old bread maker
I don't think so yeah you know the suit
you know the business suits that you
wore when you were right out of law
school like someday someone is not gonna
you also say be a tourist in your own
home yes that was really helpful go
through every single drawer re-examine
whether or not you need something right
because a lot of us have whole like
unknown areas like what is under that
bed I have no idea you know and then you
go look at it a lot of times you realize
you don't need those things you didn't
even know you had them so clearly you
don't need them much chapter four you
say cultivate helpful habits yes it's
not just one cleansing you cleaning it's
a habit yes so one great habit is the
one minute rule anything you can do in
less than a minute do without delay if
you can hang up your coat instead of
throwing down on a chair if you can rip
up in a letter and see that it you can
put it in the recycling and that just
gets rid of that scum of stuff on the
surface of life it's a little habit
that's easy to work into even a very
busy life I can make my bed in about
twenty second well I read that book make
your bed I really believe in it's like
the first choice I make every day you
have to have an orderly life and for me
making the bed is like I have control of
it yes exactly and that's again the
connection between outer order and
intercom making your bed gives you that
feeling of starting off your day in the
right way why does every room need to
have something purple okay no Danny it's
kind of that's just me being funny and
people are very literal about that but
something purple I mean something
whimsical something surprising something
special oversized undersized sparkly
every room should just have something
that makes
it feelingly special yeah yeah something
fun but I think that's everything in the
room yes and is watching this she's
thinking all those t-shirts from
political campaigns in the early 90s
that I still have that we should be
getting rid of one of them okay so you
see I kept it and in 25 years later with
paying off here's what I would say about
that t-shirt collection what sometimes
people do they really really want to
keep that signature collection but they
keep it in their main closet your main
closet is prime real estate if those are
really mementos store them somewhere
else and keep your main closet love it
excellent
bottom line make room for happiness
Gretchen Rubin thank you so much and now
to order intercom is on sale today